my boy fat a phone call on April 2 12 to
say that I might not make it through
tonight so you know I mean obviously
there they were completely torn apart
family I think it obviously it may be
like he had before me Brian Harvey is a
covert 19 survivor he spent four weeks
in a coma suffered kidney failure and
had blood clots on his lungs he now
needs intense therapy to relearn how to
walk talk and eat to me the biggest
trauma is is the fact it well you were
so active before and now you're you
can't reach for something or you've got
to ask somebody else to get something
like you know because you can you
couldn't do it
Brian's rehabilitation has started he'll
need months of specialists care we're
learning just how debilitating this
disease can be covered 19 isn't just a
respiratory condition it can be a
devastating multi-system disease
patients can suffer from heart failure
or strokes and after long spells in ICU
on ventilators there's the impact on
mental health the possible PTSD or the
anxiety caused by the trauma the scale
of rehabilitation for these kovat
survivors is huge the NHS Seacole is a
small but significant first step the
disused military hospital in Surrey has
been repurposed to provide specialist
care many patients here are medically
fit for discharge and cannot cope with
their symptoms at home this is not
something that we think will be dealt
with over just the coming weeks we're
going to need this type of extra
capacity available for months if not
years to come
the cecal will only provide local care
NHS England says more regional
specialists rehab centers will open the
warning is any delay will make an
already bad situation much worse if we
need investments we need investment in
in service provision so that there are
enough therapists in able to respond to
needs we don't want people going on to
waiting lists and services backing up
[Applause]
brian is now spending his first day at
home learning how to live with a legacy
of this brutal disease our she's Joshua
Sky News